we have a great show for you tonight
he's going to hear you I'm tired
Andy did you hear that yeah it came from
the performance base Billy raise the
door let's see what's back there
[Music]
Halloween was last week Jeff what's
going on oh it's the kids from the
Halloween sketch we rehearsed last
Thursday what about we cut the Halloween
sketch it didn't work so we cut it it's
not sure fault kids the writing was just
whoa you didn't cut it all you said was
I'm not sure and then we moved on and
nobody told them it was cut from the
show oh my god so wait a minute you
can't step in behind that stage door all
week use the pumpkin as a bathroom
oh my god you must be starving not
really
well what weren't there four kids in
that sketch yeah where's the where's the
kid who played the pirate don't worry
about it
I feel awful I really do but you God you
know what I'm gonna make it up to you
Thanksgivings coming up and so I'm gonna
put you into Thanksgiving sketch okay
how would you like that which makes me
the Thanksgiving sketch all right great
that's terrific
we'll see you guys in two weeks okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and then there were two children
[Laughter]